[Music]
coral reefs their bright vivid colors
can be seen in tropical ocean waters
around the globe
beyond their brilliant appearance lies a
hidden significance
coral are animals
though they may look like colorful
plants coral are in fact made up of tiny
animals called polyps
these invertebrates can range from the
size of a pinhead
to a bit larger than a basketball
each polyp consists of a soft sac like
body topped by a mouth covered in
stinging tentacles
to protect their soft bodies and add
support the polyps secrete limestone
skeletons or calicles
corals are mega builders
polyp callicles connect to one another
creating a colony that acts as a single
organism
as colonies grow over hundreds and
thousands of years they join with other
colonies and become reefs that can grow
to hundreds of miles long
the largest coral reef is australia's
great barrier reef which began growing
about 20 000 years ago
coral reefs are some of the most diverse
ecosystems on earth
[Music]
though they cover less than one percent
of the ocean floor
coral reefs are home to 25 of all marine
creatures
it's been estimated that up to 2 million
species inhabit coral reefs rivaling the
biodiversity of the rainforest
the reefs provide rich habitat that
helps protect young fish as they grow
coral are translucent
[Music]
coral reefs get their rainbow of colors
from algae or zoaxantholy that live in
their tissue
though corals use their tentacles to
capture some food
most of their food comes from the algae
they house
when coral becomes stressed by pollution
or other factors they evict their algae
[Music]
coral bleaching results revealing
coral's white skeletons
provide a window to the past
as coral grow their limestone skeletons
form layers similar to tree rings that
vary in composition and thickness based
on ocean conditions at the time
with some coral reefs growing for
thousands or even millions of years
scientists can study these layers to
reveal what the earth's climate may have
been like in the ancient past
unfortunately climate change is putting
coral's future in danger along with the
millions of species that inhabit the
reefs and the half billion people that
rely on reef fish for food
warming waters result in prolonged coral
bleaching that kill coral reefs or leave
them vulnerable to other threats
without significant action on climate
change our oceans could lose many of
their colorful reefs by the end of the
century
[Music]
you